das weltall ist nicht das was wir
glauben zu sehen die sichtbare materie
macht nur einen bruchteil des universums
aus fünf mal größer ist die menge der
dunklen materie ist sie jetzt gefunden
worden
klicks um science-fiction
anfang der 30er jahre des letzten
jahrhunderts vielen den astrophysikern
seltsame eigenschaften im universum auf
nichts passte zusammen
die milchstraße unsere galaxie zum
beispiel ist nicht dick genug also ihre
scheibe müsste dicker sein oder es gab
auch keine erklärung dafür wodurch die
mehr als 1000 galaxien im coma haufen
zusammen gehalten wurden
alles hatte die falschen formen bewegte
sich falsch und machte dinge die mit der
vorhandenen materie im all nicht
erklärbaren vergleich man zum beispiel
die drehung einer galaxie um sich selbst
so müssten sich die außenbereiche
langsamer ums zentrum drehen
ansonsten würde die galaxie
auseinanderfliegen das kennt man vom
karussell genau in der mitte passiert
nichts und nach außen hin werden die
fliehkräfte immer stärker und fast so
drehen sich galaxien die sternsysteme
drehen sich zu schnell um das zentrum
die hohen geschwindigkeiten am rand der
galaxien sind nur damit zu erklären dass
es zusätzliche materie gibt die dunkle
materie
seitdem wird fieberhaft nach dieser
materie gesucht doch noch hat kein
astrophysiker sie gefunden und das
obwohl es von ihr fünfmal mehr als von
der uns bekannten materie geben muss im
verdacht stehen ganz bestimmte teilchen
die sich so bis sie vor uns verstecken
so macht es den eindruck die sogenannten
vince und super vips weekly interacting
massive particles heißt das also schwach
interagierende massive teilchen niemand
hat diese teilchen bisher beobachtet da
sie mit materie so wie wir sie kennen
nicht reagieren
sie sind rein hypothetisch aber die
bisher realistischste erklärung der
dunklen materie wahrscheinlich fliegen
jede sekunde millionen solcher wird
durch unsere erde
man müsste sie eigentlich gespenster
teilchen nennen mit licht und unserer
materie treten sie nicht in irgendeinem
wechselwirkung deshalb können sie auch
einfach so durch die erde fliegen für
uns sind sie bisher mit keiner methode
wahrnehmbar sehr reagieren fast
ausschließlich mit gravitation das heißt
sie erzeugen gravitation und reagiert
da gravitation nicht ablenkt und anzieht
kann die dunkle materie durch diese
wirkung gefunden werden große massen
bilden eine sogenannte gravitationslinse
die licht ablenken
bei einer sonnenfinsternis kann man
neben der sonne zum beispiel sterne
sehen die sich eigentlich hinter ihr
befinden
und tatsächlich hat das weltraumteleskop
hubble 2007 rund um den galaxienhaufen
cl 00 24 17
mit dieser methode einen ring aus
dunkler materie gefunden dass es sie
gibt steht also außer frage
doch wie kann sie gefunden wenn wie kann
man sie direkt ermessen eine theorie
soll hier jetzt weiterhelfen sie besagt
dass wilms wenn sie kollidieren gamma
quanten aussenden
der nasa-satellit ferne ist darauf
spezialisiert gammastrahlung zu finden
und hat jetzt wohl indizien für gamma
quanten gefunden die von der kollision
von wimps ausgehen
die strahlung kommt dabei aus einem
gebiet das rund 5000 lichtjahre vom
zentrum der galaxie entfernt ist
die messungen wurden perfekt zu den
modellen der dunklen materie passen
es wäre das erste mal das gamma quanten
die von der dunklen materie ausgehen
gemessen worden wären wir werden einen
riesigen schritt weiter das universum zu
verstehen
allerdings gibt es noch ein noch
größeres rätsel materie also die uns
bekannte und die dunkle materie füllen
das weltall nur zu etwas mehr als 25
prozent aus also an viertel der rest ist
dunkle energie und von der haben wir
nicht den blassesten schimmer
es gibt aber auch dinge von denen die
forscher eine menge ahnung haben
der urknall wurde aufgedeckt big bang
theory spannendes video hierbei kriegst
du da klicken und links gibt es
natürlich auch in der video beschreibung
und sehr interessant auch wie tiere und
menschen von parasiten gesteuert werden
das gibt's da noch mehr wissenschaft
hier oben im block mit aktuellen
meldungen und wenn's gefällt abonniert
clixoom dass es kostenlos und diskutiert
mit
was haltet ihr von den jüngsten
entdeckungen kann es so etwas wie die
dunkle materie geben und wenn ja warum
was ist sie und wofür ist sie da und
so weiter und so fort diskutiert es in
den kommentaren ach ja bis dann bleibt